foreign
hi Dave welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
um so my I'm expecting my income to
increase pretty dramatically in two
years but in the meantime I'm having
trouble paying costs including two kids
in daycare so my question is is it okay
to go into debt take out a loan or is it
better to become extremely preferable
and cut costs as much as possible
uh C work more
none of the above
so what what is this guaranteed income
increase this dramatic in two years
explain to me what's going on
my wife is doing a medical residency so
in two years she'll be done with that
and get a job as a doctor yeah that will
increase things pretty dramatically
that's great and how much debt will you
guys have
um right now we have
um we own a house and aside from the
house we have about twenty five thousand
dollars in student loan debt and is she
borrowing to finish medical school
you know she has no med school debt wow
the student debt is mine okay so that
she'll graduate debt free in two years
medical school she's been doing her
residency right now but I mean she'll
grad she'll finish she'll finish and
pass her boards after residency and
become an MD
that's correct okay excellent and no
more so what's she making in residency
about seventy thousand and what are you
making
about a hundred and ten thousand you
explain to me why you can't get by on
and you have to borrow money because you
can't get by on a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars something's not right
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars
and you're gonna explain that with child
care costs hold on how much are you
paying a month in child care
uh it's about eighty thousand a year
why
you bought them in college
the the base tuition for the child
daycare we use is 25 000 per kid then we
pay extra for early care and Aftercare
and it doesn't go during the summer so
during the summer we need a nanny
uh there's there's cheaper route I know
that there it won't be as nice as I can
Dave you guys have lost your minds
there's cheaper routes oh you think
there's cheaper routes that's all I can
say because you got them in some kind of
dad gum I mean are they going to Harvard
what the crap
it is a pretty fancy day you don't think
you can downgrade yeah I think
they're not even
you're already paying 25 000 ahead
come on dude that's just dumber and crap
seriously downgrade it's time to uh it's
time to to take the the kids off filet
mignon I don't care how much money you
make there's not enough money in the
world that doesn't make that stupid gosh
find you a free summer camp anything
during the summertime we're gonna borrow
money now we're gonna take out student
loans for the four-year-old
because that's what we're coming down to
don't do it no you make 180 000 yeah I
think you need to become Frugal if
that's what the definition of living on
180 Grand is yeah you're killing me
daycare is
daycare can be expensive but it doesn't
have to be that expensive
let's just
a kid yeah I think not unbelievable I
think not I think not no
uh
yeah I think I think you can just I'm
having trouble here I think he can get I
think he can get it for half that half
that yeah yeah in Pennsylvania I gotta
believe that yeah yeah
if not if not we're opening the daycare
tomorrow I know right Dave's daycare
Philly Dave's kids heading off to Philly
I'll load up the truck and head to
Beverly oh my gosh
there's golden nose daycare Hills
this is like George's Doggy Daycare this
is people man the things we now call
Necessities in this culture so no sweet
guy you're you're a nice man I'm sorry
to make fun of you but that's crazy and
y'all need to cut that out that's not a
good investment your children are
precious and yes they're worth whatever
but you don't need to be nuts about it
yeah and and this is crazy especially
when you tell me you're talking about
borrowing money to cover this expense
among others because you got what two
kids or three kids at 25k a piece
two is 50k for daycare for two kids
that's too much I think we can
universally agree among all the listener
base yeah nope
then then guess what you've solved your
problem you don't have to borrow money
David seriously if you say out loud in
America today I can't make it on 180 000
so I need to borrow money just the fact
that you enunciated that is a problem
this is the Ramsay show